ان تصبح ركاما لكن ذلك لا يدرء عنها
القذائف والصواريخ لتظل المدينه المنكوبه
في مرمى هجمات الروس ودفاعات الاوكرانيين
في ان
وقد تلقت المدينه مزيدا من الاخبار السيئه
اذا اكد رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
ان قواته باقيه هناك بعد ان تلقى وعدا من
الجيش الروسي بتزويد تلك القوات بالاسلحه
والذخائر اللازمه ومنحها صلاحيه التصرف
والتحرك في بخموت بناء على ظروف المعركه
ويضع هذا الاعلان حدا لتهديدات بريكوجين
يوم الجمعه الماضي التي لوح فيها بسحب
مقاتله من المدينه في حال لم يتلقوا
احتياجاتهم من الذخيره عشيه احتفالات
موسكو بالانتصار على النازيين ارجح الجيش
الاوكراني اشتداد الهجوم على بخموت لكنه
اكد استمرار جنوده في الدفاع عن المدينه
المختلف على قيمتها الفعليه عسكريا
واستراتيجيا
في تجايس لدار مخموت لشبكه وحده صواريخ
تابعه لنا كتيبه من اللواء الرابع
والخمسين الاوكراني واستخدمته مستودعا
للذخيره ومنطقه انتشار مؤقته لقوات
اوكرانيه
بعيدا عن تلك الجبهه لا تهدو اله الحرب
ايضا حاكم خرسون الاوكراني اعلن سقوط
مدنيين قتله في قصف روسي استهدف مناطق
ماهوله وشبكات للبنيه التحتيه
وفي مدينه نيوكو بولو التابعه لمقاطعه
دينيبرو والمطله على المحطه النوويه قالت
السلطات الاوكرانيه ان قصفا روسيا استهدف
مناطق ماهوله بالسكان وادى الى مقتل
واصابه مدنيين فضلا عن الحاق اضرار
بانابب للغاز وخطوط للكهرباء
ويتزايد القلق من خطر احتدام القتال في
تلك المنطقه لقربها من المحطه النوويه
وفيما يبدو تصميما من كييف على توسيع نطاق
المعركه تعهد الجيش الاوكراني بتحويل شبه
جزيره القرم الى جبهه مواجهه ساخنه مع
الروس
افتتالت هجمات الطائرات المسيره على اهداف
لا سيما في مدينه سيفا ستوبول وهو ما اكده
حاكمها الروسي وقرت به
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه واصفه الهجمات بانها مجرد
بدايه